stellt euch vor ihr hättet unbegrenzt
geld zur verfügung um eure traumstadt
der zukunft zu entwerfen wie sehr die
aus vielleicht denkt ihr an ein grünes
stadtbild und saubere luft an parks an
grünflächen und effizientere
platznutzung um raum für freizeit und
einen gesunden lebensstil zu bieten
vielleicht denkt er auch an smart grids
an elektroautos oder vielleicht sogar
direkt an komplett autofreie zonen
digitalisierung und automatisierung
durchdringen und erleichtern jeden
aspekt des urbanen lebens und arbeitens
produktion und versorgung der stadt sind
hocheffizient und der strom wird zu 100
prozent aus erneuerbaren quellen
gewonnen deine vorstellung aber bevor
berlin oder köln so aussehen wollen wir
schon städte auf dem mars oder was wenn
ich sagen würde dass dieses utopia jetzt
gerade entsteht und zwar ausgerechnet in
saudi arabien einem land in dem
menschenrechte mit füßen getreten werden
und das eigentlich untrennbar mit dem
begriff erdöl verbunden ist genau dieses
land will sich jetzt neu erfinden und
wagt einen beispiellosen vorstoß in
richtung einer freieren und grünere
zukunft
leitet die öl macht damit vielleicht
einen historischen umbruch ein wird die
absolute monarchie zum offenen und
toleranten paradies und es bleibt
abzuwarten aber ich verrate schon mal so
viel für die nachhaltige utopie der
zukunft wird jetzt gerade blut vergossen
und
gozo
auf kurs
using displays mit
[Musik]
trotz des vormarsches von erneuerbaren
energien und elektromobilität ist erdöl
nach wie vor ein unglaublich wichtiger
und vielseitiger rohstoff aus ihm werden
nämlich nicht nur energie und
treibstoffe für eine menge
transportmittel gewonnen sondern auch
plastik reinigungsmittel kosmetik und
sogar kaugummis saudi arabien das reich
der ölscheichs gehört schon lange zu den
gewinnern dieses ölbedarfs und konnte
insbesondere in den 70er jahren durch
seine enormen erdölreserven zu viel
wohlstand gelangen aber diese reserven
sind eben auch endlich und all die
negativen auswirkungen die dieser
sterbende rohstoff mit sich bringt
werden immer offensichtlicher
und so will sich ausgerechnet saudi
arabien davon abwenden beziehungsweise
genauer gesagt mohammed dienst ahlmann
der saudische kronprinz der so viele
wichtige posten bekleidet dass er das
land de facto regiert als der ölpreis
2016 einen neuen tiefpunkt erreicht
kündigt er die vision trend fördern
er will die wirtschaft der arabischen
halbinsel diversifizieren und
öffentlichen sektoren wie gesundheit
infrastruktur und tourismus stärken das
geld das er für diese radikale
neuausrichtung braucht gewinnt ja unter
anderem indem er anteile des staatlichen
öl giganten saudi aramco verkauft der
konzern ist mit einem wert von über zwei
billionen dollar aktuell der teuerste
der welt und obwohl nur ein bruchteil
des unternehmens gehandelt wird brachte
alleine der börsengang 2009/10 auf einen
schlag 30 milliarden dollar ein der
größte börsengang der geschichte
insgesamt soll der staatsfonds für
vision charity umgerechnet unglaubliche
18 millionen euro bereitstellen aber die
braucht es auch denn bin salman hat
großes vor
leon ist das herzstück dieses projekts
eine megacity fast so groß wie belgien
in die alleine 500 milliarden dollar
also ein viertel des öls staatsfonds
gepumpt werden der name leon heißt so
viel wie neue zukunft und entsprechend
soll es hier alles geben was man sich in
der perfekten science fiction stadt
vorstellt modernste architektur vertical
gardening lufttaxis
lebensmittellieferungen per drohne ein
hoch fortschrittliches gesundheitssystem
und eine unfassbare menge an robotern
und cargo rhythmen die all das möglich
machen sollen tatsächlich soll neben
einmal mehr maschinen beherbergen als
die geplanten eine million bewohner so
soll ein reibungsloser ablauf garantiert
werden während sich die klügsten köpfe
aus aller welt in diesem silicon valley
2.0 austoben können und der strom für
diese gigantische infrastruktur soll
natürlich zu 100 prozent aus
erneuerbaren energien kommen erdöl
spielt hier keine rolle mehr klingt fast
zu gut um wahr zu sein und tatsächlich
beim blick auf die offizielle website
bleibt das konzept mir auch dass ein
konzept auf der seite wird irgendwie
alles sehr vage beschrieben es wird von
großen visionen und ideen gesprochen von
neuen lösungen und frischem denken aber
was mir jetzt genau ist eine stadt eine
region ein bundesland das wird nicht so
richtig klar auch konkrete zeitangaben
zum bau sucht man vergeblich
2020 vier jahre nach der ursprünglichen
enthüllung nehms kündigte been zahlmann
schließlich will leiden an und haltet
euch fest denn das habt ihr so
sicherlich noch nicht gesehen weil laien
ist sowas wie die hauptstand oder
zumindest das zentrum von lyon aber wie
der name schon vermuten lässt ist diese
stadt nicht kreisförmig sowie mehr oder
weniger jede andere stadt auf diesem
planeten sondern linien für mich
[Musik]
eine 170 kilometer lange verbindung
zwischen den sehr unterschiedlichen
landschaften über die nehrung sich
erstreckt von den stränden der westküste
über die wüste bis in die 3000 meter
hohen berge im osten da die stadt nie
breiter wird ist man innerhalb von
wenigen fußminuten mitten in der natur
überhaupt soll die stadt komplett ohne
straßen und autos auskommen alles
wichtige soll für die bewohner innerhalb
von maximal 20 minuten fußläufig
erreichbar sein und für weitere strecken
befindet sich unterhalb der stadt ein
highspeed transit auch die gesamte
physische und digitale infrastruktur
versteckt sich angenehmerweise
unterirdisch das soll an der oberfläche
ein sauberes städte design und einen
neuen einklang zwischen mensch und natur
ermöglichen und all das entsteht
scheinbar aus dem nichts eine strahlende
luxus öko metropole für investments
große visionen und thinktanks die sich
aus dem sand der unberührten arabischen
wüste erhebt das ist zumindest der
eindruck den der offizielle imagefilm
für das projekt erwecken möchte was
dabei aber ausgelassen wird in dieser
unberührte fleck erde ist unter anderem
heimat für schätzungsweise 20.000
beduinen also nomadische völker die
teilweise schon seit tausenden von
jahren in den wüsten der arabischen
halbinsel leben diese bevölkerungsgruppe
leidet schon lange unter erheblicher
diskriminierung die durch wischen trend
research ein neues ausmaß erreicht immer
mehr stammesangehörige berichten von
zwangsräumungen bei denen ganze dörfer
den bauplänen weichen müssen wer das
mutmassliche bestechungsgeld von gerade
einmal 4000 dollar nicht annehmen möchte
gegen den wirt mit drastischen mitteln
vorgegangen
[Applaus]
dieses video ging im april 2020 um die
welt jetzt zeigt den moment in dem
abdulrahim al kib von spezialkräften
erschossen wird der 47-jährige
angehörige des hofes hatte sich bis
zuletzt geweigert sein zuhause zu räumen
in den staatsmedien hieß es später der
bauer selbst habe das feuer eröffnet und
wäre deswegen neutralisiert worden in
einer videobotschaft einen tag vorher
hatte als motiv vermutet dass die
staatsmedien die exekution auf diese
weise vertuschen würden im video
berichtet er generell über die
rücksichtlose vorgehensweise des
kronprinzen nennt sie staatsterrorismus
die botschaft wurde unter anderem von
der in london lebenden aktivisten alaa
al hiti geteilt als journalistin setzt
sie sich für die erfolg ein und klärt
schon länger über die ereignisse rund um
den bau von mehr um auf ursprünglich
habe es geheißen die robert hat würden
weitreichend von neon profitieren jetzt
berichtet alter von stammesangehörigen
die bedroht belästigt und gewaltsam aus
ihren häusern entfernt werden strom
zufuhren würden gekappt feuer gelegt und
ist seit aktuellste seien weitere 15
menschen verschwunden mit hilfe des
britischen anwalts rodney dixon wurde
der fall beim menschenrechtsrat der
vereinten nationen eingereicht es wäre
nicht das erste mal dass winzer man sich
als brutaler herrscher entpuppt er führt
seit jahren einen erbitterten krieg im
jemen und wird für die ermordung des
journalisten und regierungskritikers
jamaica shogi 2018 verantwortlich
gemacht auch alle haiti wird inzwischen
von scotland yard wegen morddrohungen
beschützt
[Musik]
nee um erinnert an die giga projekte aus
dubai gerade die vereinigten arabischen
emirate sind ja dafür bekannt immer noch
höhere noch luxuriösere wolkenkratzer
oder direkt ganze insel gruppen aus dem
nichts entstehen zu lassen aber nicht
selten verlaufen diese prestige projekte
wieder im sand manchmal wortwörtlich nun
will es saudi arabien ihren nachbarn
scheinbar gleich tun mit dem großen
unterschied dass es beim um weitaus mehr
geht als nur ein großes bauprojekt für
touristen es ist auch ein konflikt um
das alte und das neue saudi arabien denn
mit vision trendy ver.di hat sich bin
salman nicht nur zum ziel gesetzt das
land wirtschaftlich und umweltpolitisch
zu reformieren sondern es auch gegenüber
westlicher werte zu öffnen leon und
laien als sonderwirtschaftszonen spielen
da eine sehr wichtige rolle sie sind so
etwas wie ein staat im staat mit eigenen
gesetzen und einer lebensqualität um die
uns die welt beneidet wird wie es auf
der website steht in der praxis heißt
das jede denkbare form der unterhaltung
soll angeboten werden und sogar alkohol
soll erlaubt sein was die scharia also
das religiöse rechts des islam
eigentlich komplett verbietet zur vision
trendy ver.di gehört also auch ein
prozess der trennung von staat und
religion aber für wiens ahlmann haben
gruppen wie die wie du ihnen in diesem
wandel scheinbar nicht nur keinen platz
sie werden brutal aus dem weg geräumt
und sind wir mal ehrlich beim verkauf
von gerade einmal 1,5 prozent von saudi
aramco kann man auch nicht wirklich von
einem öl ausstieg sprechen vielleicht
geht es saudi arabien also gar nicht so
sehr darum wirklich unabhängiger vom öl
zu werden und eine grüne revolution
anzuführen vielleicht will man eher
greenwashing betreiben und die sowieso
schon große wirtschaftskraft des landes
nutzen um sich im globalen vergleich
noch besser zu positionieren
vielleicht will man auch von
saudi-arabiens politik der unterdrückung
der verbrechen und der
menschenrechtsverletzungen ablenken und
wie könnte man das besser hinkriegen als
mit der utopie einer stadt die so
fortschrittlich und so weltoffen ist das
aufstreben des start-ups mit den
innovativsten ideen ganz von alleine
kommen
soviel zu neon und bleiben es war kein
einfaches video in unserer recherche und
in der produktion und trotzdem mussten
wir es auf jeden fall machen und jetzt
wirklich sehr eure meinung interessieren
sind neon und will ein zukunftsweisend
und grün und nachhaltig oder doch eher
ein politischer schachzug und ablenkung
und greenwashing lasst uns diskutieren
schreibt mir die kommentare aber bitte
wie immer faktenbasiert und sachlich
danke fürs zuschauern und wie immer bis
zum nächsten mal bleibt neugierig
patrick